[Music]
about 10 years ago we saw an uptick in
marriage but that was fairly short-lived
rates are right now plunging again down
to half what they were of the peak in
1972. so is this a sign of a more
liberated society
we're delighted to have the new
statesman writer louise perry writing
for us in the spectator about this
phenomenon she has a book now out called
the case against the sexual revolution
louise great to have you with us and why
do you think that the marriage rates are
going down isn't this a sign of social
progress
so
the
um crucial piece of legislation here is
the divorce reform act in 1969
which was uh one of the sort of the
great pieces of liberalizing legislation
in the the period of the beginning of
the sexual revolution
um
what's really interesting i when i was
writing the book actually i went back
and i read hansard and i read the
debates around that piece of legislation
and um
the view at the time
was that this was just a very minor
piece of
piece of um
liberalization that would just make life
a little bit easier for people who were
in desperately unhappy marriages and and
needed to be out of them this is of
course at the time when it was really
hard to get a divorce and you had to
prove you had to prove adultery
intolerable cruelty etc um and so the
view from all of the
the uh the revolutionaries they didn't
know their revolutionaries at the time
was that you just a little tweak and it
would make things just that little bit
simpler that a little bit kinder to
people who were desperate to get
divorced
um of course that's not what happened at
all what happens immediately you look at
the graph of divorce rates in the uk and
1969 is just this explosion
um and you see divorce climbs and climbs
it peaks in the 1970s and then it's kind
of leveled off or or just uh
bounced around a little bit since then
but that's not because marriages are
becoming
longer it's because people are not
getting married in the first place and
what seems to have happened is that
as soon as you sort of reach this
threshold where it was no longer assumed
that you would be married for life
you end up with this kind of
acceleration effect
where
previously you would only consider a
divorce if your marriage was desperately
unhappy and then it became
the threshold became a little bit lower
and a little bit lower and a little bit
lower and now we're at the stage where
about half of children are not born in
wedlock which is historically
unprecedented and clearly there have
been beneficiaries of that i completely
acknowledge that there are some
marriages that are miserable and abusive
and desperately need to end and people
should be able to earn those marriages
but i'm not convinced by the idea that
this has been liberation for everyone i
particularly think that children have
suffered as a consequence of this and i
think poor women in particular have
suffered as well because what we know
from the data is that the
best environment for a stable and
prosperous
family in which to raise children is a
married couple who stay married
but is that necessarily the i mean is
marriage the data show that marriage is
better than two people cohabiting
because what you can what you get quite
a lot in britain and um and to take
sweden for example my wife is swedish
when i got when i proposed to her
her friends were kind of shocked so we
didn't she wasn't even pregnant you know
in sweden the way things work out is you
have a baby if things go well then you
might get have another baby if things go
well you might then get married but it
doesn't um it's difficult to say that
swedish society is any sort of worse
than british because they've got a
cohabiting tradition so is cohabitation
demonstrably worse than marriage for the
child
i don't know the situation in sweden i
wonder if common law marriage is
recognized in law there because that
does change things
one of the things a lot of people don't
realize here is that we there there
aren't you have no rights um unless you
are married formally to someone so you
you there there are all sorts of
negative consequences if you are if
someone dies or you split and you're not
formally married in terms of things like
uh inheritance tax and you know other
other rights that marry couples but you
have civil partnerships here the blair
government introduced this sort of
marriage light at the time
but then interestingly that just seems
to have been
um
i mean it is in technical terms
basically the same as being married just
without the religious aspect it gives
you all of the legal entitlements
doesn't it people do want to get married
but still want the protection the legal
protection of inheritance and whatnot
but that's been a flop hazards
well it doesn't seem to have had the
uptake that one might have expected
people are just
choosing to cohabit and the problem with
cohabitation
longer term and in thinking about
children's own is couples who are
cohabiting are much more likely to split
because there seems to be a
when it is just that little bit more
difficult to you know every relationship
across
across a lifetime life is very long you
will go through periods of not liking
each other as much and
it seems that when you've got
when it's hard to divorce people tend to
stick with it
and are more likely to push through the
tough times and get to
and um
get to a happier stage where they you
know are pleased to still be together
but if divorce is easy or if
just splitting because you're not even
married in the first place is easy
we we see in the data that people are
much more likely to do it and actually
likely to regret it i was really
surprised to read data on the proportion
of divorce people who regret getting
divorced in this country it's between
about a third and a half
um yeah i know it's really high
some of our listeners might be find it
strange this argument coming from you a
new statesman writer i mean typically
the rights have been the one talking
about family values and trying to make
it and trying to resist um divorce
reform and the left has been the one
arguing for more liberal structures do
you think the left have miscalculated
here that marriage is a progressive
force
i mean if you look at the data the class
skew
on marriage is absolutely incredible in
this country also in the states and in
other places
you get a
um a liberal elite who tend to talk
negatively about marriage and are
opposed to marriage incentives in policy
making and so forth but they are
actually the group of people who are
most likely to themselves get married
and stay married
um so there's a kind of
the if you've heard the expression
luxury belief rob henderson's um
idea of a an idea which confers status
on
rich people and harms poor people
the
anti-marriage
sexual revolution idea is a really great
example of a luxury belief because it's
deeply unfashionable on the left to talk
about marriage being a force for good
but actually
people who
people in elite positions people who who
who are um wealthier up middle classes
for themselves love marriage
and and are the group most likely to
choose it for themselves and and wish it
for their children and so on they're
just reluctant to prescribe it for the
rest of society which actually
disproportionately harms poorer people
right so do you think in this case the
progressive cause should be
to promote marriage i mean it seems then
unlikely but i don't know but from what
you're saying if the figures show as you
suggest that marriage first of all is a
tool that benefits people that the rich
tend to get married a lot even though
they advocate liberalism and that then
people in poorer communities are
suffering from the lack of it is this um
a cause which left ought to take up and
what can you do to promote marriage it
sounds a bit hectoring doesn't it for
for any politician to be suggesting to
somebody else how the shooter shouldn't
live their lives
as i say deeply deeply unfashionable but
i think that if we if we're thinking
about children in particular and if
we're concerned about um the various
adverse outcomes that come for children
of of not growing up in a house with
their fathers at home talking about
things like higher incarceration rates
for boys higher teen pregnancy rates for
girls
poorer mental health for both sexes in
all sorts of ways we know that there is
this this institution you know now now
mostly dead which can improve all of
those outcomes
and actually you know there are all
sorts of ways in in this country that
marriage is actually disincentivized by
the state for instance we don't assess
people's
tax
on the basis of a family it is um
there's very few advantages from being
married in terms of your tax
arrangements because you still have to
pay tax on an individual basis which
means that a single earner household
actually ends up paying a lot more tax
than a dual earner household which is
has been deliberately designed um by the
new labour government that's the sort of
policy that would be quite easy to
change and would provide just that
little little bit of incentive for
people to choose to get married and
choose to stay married with all of the
benefits that brings in terms of both
for individuals and also for families if
this isn't really creeping through in
policy i wonder if it's creeping through
in popular culture let's take for
example beyonce or a great feminist icon
now she um argued about um well quite a
few years ago now that women should be
insisting upon marriage if you like it
she said you should put a ring on it do
you think this will be a feminist um
creed occur
well
now
don't know i mean i where beyonce goes i
suppose we all follow but um
uh i mean i think it ought to be and i
think i think what's really interesting
i write about this in the piece at the
end is that um a lot of um feminist or
progressives who rail against marriage
because it's associated with the
religious right and all of this it's
old-fashioned it's terrible
find ways of kind of reinventing
marriage because actually the the like
central idea of having some sort of
formal legal bond to the person
with whom you're in a sex relationship
with and even more so with whom you have
a child with there's actually a great
deal of of wisdom to that there's a
reason that he has persisted down the
ages
and so you have various sort of
proposals which sound actually an awful
lot like marriage
but um
just don't have that that that term i
think i was fascinated in your article
that you mentioned then something called
radical monogamy a phrase i hadn't heard
acros come across before but it's
mentioned by vice magazine recently what
is radical monogamy and is it just
another word for marriage yeah radical
monogamy apparently is when you
deliberately choose to be monogamous
having sort of
properly assessed all of the other
options rather than just
being monogamous by default because
that's what the culture tells you you
ought to do i do not see any meaningful
difference between those two things the
outcome is exactly the same and it's a
good one you know we know i mean on the
the subject of polyamory so that's
what's been presented as the alternative
to monogamy right and there are and
there are various pushes to um to
formalize polyamory and permit um
permit multiple marriages and so on i
don't know if they're gonna go anywhere
one of the things i write about in the
book
is that um
monogamous marriage is not only good for
individuals with children it also has
effects on the whole of our society
which are really remarkable
societies where monogamous marriages
formalized in law
tend to be more prosperous they tend to
have lower rates of violence they don't
have lower rates of domestic abuse and
child abuse there are all sorts of ways
that you know because all of this is
networks right like kind of the point
i'm trying to make in the book is this
isn't just about individual choices
isn't just about individual freedom this
is thinking about
the what the well-being of society as a
whole
and
monogamous marriage has turned out
historically to be this amazing tool for
promoting um a flourishing society
[Music]
you